>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> David Plylar: First of all,
thank you very much for being here.
I'm very pleased to see
this amount people here.
This is great, because it's
supposed to be a very comfortable,
casual type of interaction here.
I will be playing a few pieces, and
I'll play some examples of things,
but other than that, it's
really just a chance to talk
about what's going on,
and I'll show you some
of these very interesting
manuscripts that we have
at the Library of Congress.
I should say, first of all,
my name is David Plyler,
and I work in the Music Division.
One of my great interests
in music, really, is Liszt,
the music of Franz Liszt.
I've given a few talks
before, you might have known
about the funeral odes that we also
have at the Library of Congress
and the historical
Hungarian portraits.
A lot of these pieces tend
to be late in Liszt's life
when he composed them,
and for some reason,
I'm particularly drawn to those.
What we're going to be looking at
today is the largest collection
of manuscript sources for
the third book, third year,
of the Annees de Pelerinage,
the years of pilgrimage.
The first two books came
out and, I think, the 1850s,
although they were written in the
1830s, various pieces from them.
The first one was the Swiss volume.
The second one was the Italy volume,
and the third one is sometimes kind
of erroneously called Italy,
but is it based on kind
of more spiritual types of things
in Liszt's life in the 1870s,
for the most part, although
he continued to make revisions
to these pieces up until
their publication in 1883.
It's one of, I think it's
widely regarded as one
of his best late sets of piano
pieces, with good reason.
They're very -- to me,
the very visionary works,
and very meaningful.
You can just tell that he
put a great deal into them.
One of the most famous pieces in
the piano literature happens to come
from this Les jeux d'eaux a la
Villa d'Este, which is, you know,
the fount of all fountains
that often came after it
with the Ravel and Debussy.
That work, I will not be
playing today, thankfully for me,
because it's a monster,
but it's a beautiful piece
and a wonderful piece, but we do
not have the material for that work.
What we do have are the materials
for the first three pieces
of the set and then the
fifth work in the set,
I thought I would just
take them in order,
because they offered different
aspects of the editing process
and the sketch process that
will go take a look at.
So the first piece, I believe,
is one of Liszt's favorite pieces
of his towards end of
his life called Angelus,
and it's basically he subtitles
it A Prayer to The Guardian Angel.
He made, I think there's six
different versions for the piano
of this piece before you get to the
final version, and there's also,
potentially, two or three
versions for string quartet.
There's also another version for
string quintet or string orchestra,
and these all come into play
in kind of interesting ways
with the manuscripts that we
have at the Library of Congress.
The one that gets referenced
in literature the most is a
copyist manuscript by a student
of Liszt named Ricard Burmeister,
and he, at least that's what's given
to us in an unknown hand
on the copyist manuscript.
So we think it was his, but you can
see Liszt's annotations and going
over it in this manuscript and
we'll be of the take a look
at that physically over here.
We have a second round
that is never referenced,
at least that I can find, in the
same hand, Burmeister otherwise,
where he takes the edits of
the first one and puts them
into the second version, and
it's getting awfully close
to the final version, but
is still not quite there,
and the different types of
alternate things that come
up in this particular piece tend
to be additions for decision
to make or repeat of an idea.
This is a -- it's actually
interesting excuse me.
I just need a quick drink.
This idea that the repeat is kind
of central to Liszt in general.
The way that he puts mature
out there often involves a
statement and then a restatement.
Sometimes that restatement is in
another key or something like that,
but it's kind of a central thing.
If you listen to most of the
Liszt pieces that you like,
you'll notice that there is
this type of developed repeat
or a literal repeat of some of
the expository types of material.
What becomes interesting
is when these types
of repeats have an echo effect on a
more microlevel, or they have kind
of an insertion or
an elongation effect.
And so those are the types of things
that we'll see the
Liszt, in the Angelus.
So first time just to play a couple
of these examples of the type
of material that are getting
this type of treatment repeated.
So to give you context, here's
the version without the repeat.
[ Music ]
So what wasn't repeated, which
is a little bit hard to know
when you haven't heard it repeated,
was just this little
chunk right here.
[ Music ]
So in the final version, he
adds -- he does it twice.
[ Music ]
And then it continues on.
So a very minor thing, but it's
the kind of thing that tends
to change the pacing
of the entire work.
Another example of this.
Another example of this
takes an earlier version
that was further explored,
and I'm kind of extrapolating
what I think Liszt was going to do
in this version, and this is
where in the final version,
what you have is this.
[ Music ]
So the part that repeated was this.
So it was originally not repeated,
and in fact, the harmonic rhythm
of the entire section that comes
after it was quite different
but the same harmonically,
but it's just more compacted.
It sounded like --
[ Music ]
Something like that.
The rest of the material
is obscured.
Liszt crossed off all these
things are wrote on top of them.
So it's not easy to tell
exactly what he's doing.
But an earlier version of this
piece, he does that sort of a thing.
So that's another type of
change that you'll find.
I won't lay this example,
but there are things
such as little margin
additions that come into play.
So he'll be doing something and
then just do it again in the margin
as an afterthought, as another
repeated thing, but again,
it's the same idea, just
repeating an idea, a small,
usually two measures long.
Then we have a different way
of dealing with transitions.
So here are a couple of
examples of ways that Liszt dealt
with a transitional
passage, or actually,
the end of this particular section.
[ Music ]
So that's the first one.
It's in the earliest manuscript,
and he crosses this out,
and in its place, but
something like this.
[ Music ]
So that's close to the final
version but not yet there.
In that copyist manuscript
is the second one,
he does put the final
version, after crossing
that which we just heard out.
He puts that in.
So you'll hear that in a moment.
Another type of change has
to do with the repetition
of two-bar chunks, as well, but
in this case, they're chunks
that evolve in terms of where
the music is moving from.
I apologize if I have to
go back and forth so much.
I made versions of all the
manuscripts on top of each other,
so that you can kind of see them,
but it makes it a little bit
awkward when I try to find them.
Okay, so here's the earliest
version of this passage.
[ Music ]
Here's the second version.
Now there are two very
important differences here.
I mean, relative to some of
the other changes maybe not
that important, but I think
they're quite important.
You hear this.
[ Music ]
And the new edition is adding this.
So it just does something to the
spacing in the pacing of the work,
and there's also a
difference comes into play
with respect to the voicing.
So the octaves.
So you hear this in
the first version.
[ Music ]
You have this low bass
octave included,
and when he changes,
it goes to this.
[ Music ]
So you lose that low octave,
and I think that there's a
practical reason for this,
because Liszt was very much,
he always does the
octaves mostly for color.
It's not so much about volume
or something like that.
In this case, I think he ended
up liking that particular color
of the just using the one octave
because he was making an
alternate version for harmonium,
and so in the final version of
the piece that was published,
there's this one particular passage,
the biggest passage of work,
where you have harmonium
option available.
The harmonium range is not as
large as that of the piano.
So it's been reduced, and that's
why it's given us another option.
In the manuscript that we have,
one of the manuscripts that we have
at this, Liszt put in
three different spots
where he has alternate harmonium
parts that lose this octave
in the appropriate spots, and
so that's one of the reasons
that I think it's not there.
One the other interesting things
about this I should say is
that both manuscripts that we
have related to Angelus say
that they're transcriptions
from the string quartet version,
which is a little -- is probably
just wrong, but it also could be
that Liszt made several
different versions
of the string quartet version,
and then this particular
copyist was working from that,
and I'm not quite sure which
it is, but the timing of it,
the earliest drafts that come from
well before and they're for piano,
and they're for this
1882 draft that we have.
But it's interesting that it
still kind of find its place
until its publication in 1883.
You get this real sense of
the piece is not finalized,
although earlier iterations
are beautiful
and quite interesting
and worth turning out.
On that note, I should say
that are in if you aware
of the pianist Leslie Howard?
He is a very interesting pianist
and musicologist who did --
he's in the Guinness
Book of World Records
for doing largest solo recording
product of a pianist ever,
and that is the complete
piano works of Liszt.
That includes 99 CDs plus.
So it's -- and he's still going
and doing on projects now.
So I mean, I'm not sure how
he really got through it,
but he plays through five of the
six versions of Angelus in that set,
and there are a few others that
he actually doesn't play some
of the alternatives that
we're going to hear today.
So I imagine eventually he might
add another supplemental volume
to include these things.
But he does, if you want to
hear these things in the context
of an entire performance,
it's worth checking out.
Just so you're aware of that.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
They do. So the question was how
do you know which one is which?
The problem is that you have
to always update unless
you find a new one.
But often, they'll use what
we call serial numbers.
There's a new catalog
is been in the works
for 20 something years
that's coming out.
But they have earlier drafts that
are definitely given as 162A/i,
and so that way you can at least
add a -- by the third draft,
you can add a 3 or
something like that to it.
So that's definitely
something that they do.
So let's go ahead -- I'm just
going to give you a sense
of what the final version
of this piece sounds like,
and then we'll move
onto the next one.
So this is the Angelus.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
So it's a lovely piece.
You can hear very
proto-Impressionist in some ways.
Something that I left out is
these little details like this,
these two measures were
left out of the original.
[ Music ]
Just that used to be.
So there's little details
like that that just kind
of have this very nice effect.
One thing that is a hallmark
of this particular piano set is
that you have a lot of these endings
that are just single-line gestures,
which may seem unusual for Liszt,
but as he was getting older
and into more religious aspects
of his music, they often tend
to be there, and often,
they're just beautifully done
and simply put forward.
So we're going to move
on to the next work,
which is the most recent
acquisition for the library.
It's a very exciting one, because
it's the -- for the first Trinity,
which is a Cyprus Trinities, and
it was unknown before it came
onto the market that there was
this manuscript even exists.
In fact, it's two manuscripts.
It's a holograph manuscript in
Liszt's hand, and then you have
that represents an
early version of it,
and then you have a copyist
manuscript with further corrections
and changes also in Liszt's hand.
So it's a very different
kind of a piece.
A very dark piece, and
it's -- so it's like a --
well, maybe like a dirge or
something like that is kind
of the more, other
way to describe it.
Let me just pull it out here.
So with this one, what I'm
going to do is show you some
of the main points of departure
from the original in this one,
and it starts to deviate
quite a bit.
There was actually an entirely
new middle section to the piece
that people haven't heard, and
you can see why Liszt moved away
from us, but you can also see
how he incorporates elements
of these things that he ends of
getting rid of in other pieces
of the set so it helps to
actually make argument for the set
of the whole third book is being a
-- making sense together as a cycle.
So it helps to contribute to
that, just having these sketches
and these other types of materials.
So on the first page of it,
there's actually a flap,
and I found some material
on the underside of flap
that gives a little bit of a sense
of what he might have
been going for.
So here's how it is,
this little passage.
Here's how it is the final version.
[ Music ]
Sets the final version.
Here's an original
version that I kind
of made fit I think the way he
was originally looking at it.
[ Music ]
See, hear a very different
descending line
and also a little slightly
faster harmonic rhythm there.
So that's the first spot.
So here's another way.
He's transitioning
into kind of a very,
another lugubrious middle section,
and it seems like he gets lost a
little bit, and he crosses this out
and eventually, he's not
expect anybody to do this.
So this is really unfair actually,
because Liszt said no to this,
but I'm playing it anyway.
So don't hold it against him
if you don't make something,
but there are elements of it
that are quite beautiful
in of themselves.
So I think, you know,
we can veto Liszt here
and say let's hear it anyway.
[ Music ]
And that's instead of --
So it's like this extension.
Then after this big section, it
goes in a very different direction.
So I'm going to play --
this is material that he didn't do
anything with, although it, again,
appeared later, and
we hear stuff like it.
So after we've been building
up, it turns into this.
[ Music ]
So I just butchered that
end part, but that's --
you get the idea that there's
this material that's being used,
and it sounds slightly familiar,
because he did end up using it
in the final version,
just a very different way.
So first of all, this --
[ Music ]
This new lead material
we've heard before
from the section preceding it, but
this stuff, where it's going --
[ Music ]
That kind of material is used quite
differently, and the way that --
so what you'll hear, and I'll try
to play this a little bit
slower see you can hear it.
It gets turned into this
kind of massive buildup.
[ Music ]
So this little offset thing
eventually morphs into that,
and it's role there is
transitional between sections.
So it's something like a proto
idea that he thought of a way
to do something different
with that later.
Then towards the end, we get this
gorgeous chordal section that goes
through the very end, and he had
several different ideas about how
to handle this, and
I'm going to pull up --
I'm going to do a combination
of the two versions
that have been secured back to back,
instead of playing
the whole thing twice.
So what's interesting
here is that --
I'll just play this little section
and then I'll play another
section that's slightly elongated.
[ Music ]
Then it continues from there.
So it's this really beautiful
thing that he rejected.
So instead of that, here's a second
version had something similar
to that, but a kind of ending
at this -- as it moves on.
Oh, here it is.
So just from the very
end of that, you hear --
[ Music ]
So that's a very different type
of idea, and this is the second --
a copyist manuscript
that Liszt added
that in and then crossed it out.
So the actual version of
that is played with it also.
So you hear instead --
[ Music ]
And then it goes on from there.
The last thing I'll show to you
about this piece until we get
to the end are these multiple
temps that he had at this change,
when I get to the 4:4 section
at the end of the piece,
which I'll just play a
little bit of what it turns
out in the final version,
and it just has this --
it comes to rest here.
[ Music ]
And it continues like this.
You'll hear, in a moment, but
in the version that he did,
his first attempt was this.
[ Music ]
It alternates between
those two chords.
That he goes off a little bit
and it doesn't quite work out.
So he starts over and
he goes to this.
[ Music ]
Without the C sharp I added.
So he's still trying to figure
out what to do harmonically here,
and I think that his instincts
were that you could do all kinds
of things, but maybe it was
better to be simpler in the end,
and so I'm going to
play through this piece
so you can hear what it's like, and
just know that there's just a lot
of depth in this manuscript that's
really interesting to look at.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Oh, sorry, so Aux cypres
de la Villa d'Este,
or in this manuscript version, it
was the [inaudible] de Villa d'Este.
So the cypress trees, and
then it has a subtext Trinity.
So like an elegy.
That's the word I was looking for.
That's better than dirge, I think.
This opening is fantastic,
because it has --
it's in G minor, but you
hear B flat to F sharp,
and that's how it's spelled.
And so immediately,
you're playing a third,
but it looks like you're
playing a fourth.
So he likes sets it up
so interestingly, to me.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
So I don't know if you caught
it there, but in the center,
I tried to pretend like I was trying
something different in the way
that Liszt did in the manuscript
to give it a more realistic
-- yeah, I mean, maybe.
But yeah, no, he's definitely -- you
know, it's one thing you can tell
from the manuscripts is that Liszt
was, of course, a great improviser,
and sometimes, and this is what
you'll see in this next piece
that we're going to
take a look at is
that what he would do is basically
create a continuity draft,
where you come up with an
idea that maybe is not going
to be the final idea, but it's
stuck in there, so that by the time
that he gets around to
rewriting it or editing it,
he has a full kind of
section to deal with.
So that is something that he
does in some other pieces.
So the next piece we're
going to take a look
at actually has the same
name and our manuscript.
It's Danse Epressin der Ville
d'Este [assumed spelling],
and ends up having the same
name in the final set, as well,
but it's called the second Trinity.
So this one is quite
beautiful and quite interesting
in a different way, and what we find
from the manuscripts here,
and this is a sketch.
It's not a complete draft.
There's another continuity
draft that's related
to this that's been recorded,
but not this section,
the sketch that we're
going to take a look at.
But you can already
see that he's working
with different harmonies
and things like that.
So that's kind of one of the
more interesting things coming
into play here.
So for instance, from the
very opening of the piece,
the original way that
he had it was this.
[ Music ]
And then in the final way it's --
So the difference there is
that he puts and F sharp
in the base to then move down.
That's the only difference, but --
[ Music ]
But it ends up having
this very different feel
to it when it starts --
[ Music ]
It's just crunchier
and more chromatic,
even though that's not
a whole step there.
So that's one of the
things that comes into play.
Also, I should mention
this all along,
is that there's this thematic
transformation is happening
with these very simple
melodies throughout,
and so in the final version,
the one that matters here is --
[ Music ]
And then eventually you hear.
Just an extension of that idea,
but in the initial drafts,
Liszt had a very different idea.
He changed that melodic
line to this.
[ Music ]
So it's not that -- does leap down
and then a chromatic scale up.
It's a very interesting other
type of alternative melody,
and then that leads into some
different kind of material,
and the final version we hear --
[ Music ]
In this one, we hear this.
The first, early version,
we hear this.
[ Music ]
There's nothing inherently better
about what he ended up with.
In fact, that one has a
resolution, more dissonance to it,
it's kind of interesting.
You would say more
interesting in the abstract
that maybe didn't quite
fit the way he wanted it
to than the actual piece.
He then turns that, what was --
[ Music ]
That idea gets turned into a
bigger one when it comes back.
[ Music ]
And the same thing.
So that same kind of
different way of dealing
with those chords comes into play.
When he starts -- introduces
another theme --
[ Music ]
That's how he ends up.
That's where he ends up, but in
the original version, it's this.
[ Music ]
So we lose a couple of measures,
and the harmonic rhythm is
very different also there.
So that's one of the changes, and
then we have the next section,
another substantial type of change.
Here's how it was originally
in the early manuscripts.
[ Music ]
And so forth.
Next doing -- this is a weird
thing to turn the pages for.
So kudos to Nick.
Thank you.
In the final version, it's this.
[ Music ]
So it's a bit fuller, more chords,
and a little bit more
ostentatious, if you will.
Then in the -- at the
end of that section,
he keeps it very simple
in the final version.
[ Music ]
But in the original
version it was this.
[ Music ]
So quite a different harmonic
setting of that same material,
which I think is kind of fascinating
to see, but he moved away from that.
Then we get this kind of not bizarre
section but one that's often hard
to make heads or tails out of
with these arpeggios that go up.
[ Music ]
I think they're meant to go up to
the top and kind of spill down.
In the original version,
what we have is this.
[ Music ]
So the foreshortened version,
and then kind of a very
simplified moving on.
[ Music ]
Now this transition, where
it's going from this,
and I have to play
these back to back seat
and here they sound
like -- it goes to this.
[ Music ]
When we hear the full thing, we
hear that list actually expands
that entire section, but by the
time it gets to that similar passage
that we just heard, he's changed
it quite a bit into this very kind
of hauntingly beautiful
idea, and that's, again,
it's all based on that same thing.
Same idea.
[ Music ]
So it's added a contrapuntal
line, as well.
So it's a very interesting
change that he makes there.
He does the same thing
with the repeated section.
Remember I said lots of
these things come in two
with the different versions,
and then we lose a big chunk,
where he just goes into
different territory,
and this territory sounds like this.
[ Music ]
And then it moves into what you
think is going to be B major.
[ Music ]
I checked the manuscript,
and it definitely has the
four sharps, A natural there.
So that's a similar treatment that
you heard earlier in that version.
In the version that he ends up
with, sounds more like this.
[ Music ]
So the role of the
tremolo is reversed.
So in this case, now you
have the melody in the bass
and the tremolo on the right hand.
Whereas, originally,
they were opposite.
The last thing I think I'll show
about this particular
version is another interesting
harmonic revival.
So after this passage of this
figure stuff get done, it goes.
[ Music ]
And the second one again is --
And then, after this point,
it just kind of drifts away.
There's a little bit of arpeggios
stuff, and then it just kind
of goes away, and we're close
to the end of the piece,
but it's just not quite the end.
So now I'm going to
play through this one.
You can hear with the
final version is.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
So the last piece we'll
take a look at --
first of all, you'll notice that it
again had that single-line ending,
which is just kind of an
inspired stroke there,
but it's also something that keep
consistent throughout the piece
as a whole.
This last piece that I'm going
to play, which is the last one
that we have, is the
fifth in the series.
It's last one we have
manuscript material for.
It deviates quite significantly
from what the final version is.
So I'll play passages here that
are just completely different.
It also dates earlier.
I believe 1867 might be
around the first draft,
but it's not quite clear when
it was, but it's another type
of trinity basically, but this
time, the title Sunt Lacrimae Rerum,
There are Tears for These Things.
And he says it's in a Hungarian
mode, and most likely referring
to the 1848/1849 revolution
and also the types of friends
that he lost at that time.
One reason that it's a
definite tie in for that is
that the historical Hungarian
portraits that he wrote
around in the 1870s,
a little bit later,
also very specifically named
these people, some of whom died
in the revolution, and then he also
uses some of the similar material,
if not the same, in certain spots.
So that's one way we kind
of hear what's going on.
So I'll just play a couple
major different [inaudible]
in the final version.
[ Music ]
And it comes back to it there.
Again, Liszt crossed this out.
So he doesn't want you to hear
it, but we played it anyway.
So in the original, it doesn't
have that whole section.
This idea that is here
is side by side.
In the original version,
we hear this.
[ Music ]
The final version, we hear this.
So we have an extension
by a measure.
This happens three other places with
similar types of ideas like that.
I will play them for
you, but that is --
these are additions that he
made in the later versions,
as opposed to subtractions.
So [inaudible] to do that.
There are little differences
that you find --
[ Music ]
You really fast repetitions, where
in the final version, it's --
[ Music ]
Just little things like
that, that means more
to the pianist that it's changed.
So it's a little easier to
play in the later version.
So he was kind there at least, and
then you have this really strange,
tumultuous, low area that ends in
a cadenza in the original version,
and here's what that sounds like.
I won't give away the nice
surprises in the original but --
[ Music ]
And then he actually has
an alternate version,
and I'll just play the
end of that, which is --
[ Music ]
And so that's very different
from the final version,
which you'll hear what he
does differently there.
Then we get to the
more Hungarian section,
which has a very boring
accompaniment part at the beginning.
At least that's my opinion.
[ Music ]
It kind of continues like that.
Some differences from the
original, which you'll hear,
or the final, which you'll hear.
Then we have another type
of change, which is this.
[ Music ]
Then it continues something
like this.
[ Music ]
It continues on, just
keeping that same basic --
[ Music ]
But I can't see it underneath.
It's something like that.
Then he gives up on that.
I don't think he actually
gives up on it.
I think he just covers it up
with the music that you hear,
and then you get to this very
wild ending, which is harder --
well, I shouldn't say that.
I'll jinx myself.
But harder, in some ways, then
the final version that he did.
He definitely has these
triplets in the right-hand,
as opposed to [inaudible]
in the final version.
[ Music ]
That's how he ends the piece.
You'll hear that it's quite
different than what he ends
up going for, and actually,
it seems a bit more positive
than what he finally
ends up going with.
The last thing I want to do
is I'm just going to play
through this piece, and I
personally want to thank everybody
for being here, and afterwards,
I'll be happy to show you some
of the manuscript items that
we have up here and turn pages
for you and stuff like that.
So it's kind of part of the point
is just to get a chance to look
at the actual things and see how --
what kind of adaptations
I've made from them.
All right, thanks.
So this is Sunt Lacrimae Rerum.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
So thanks again for coming, and
that was kind of a strange ending.
We can talk about that, too,
but why don't you come on up
and take a look at the manuscript.
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.